or the houseless venom 2 trailer we
reacted to the video yesterday Warren
said it was gonna come out he's got a
pretty good track record I don't know I
mean I don't know why he would make
something like that up
should we call him I guess maybe I don't
know I mean he's the one who let us know
hey man hey what's up guys
hey dude so um listen what's what's
going on with this venom - crap I mean
you we did video yesterday you hit me up
saying that there's gonna be a venom 2
trailer coming out and uh don't say
anything on the Internet today yeah yeah
sorry about that
apparently that photo that Andy Serkis
apparently posted his Instagram was fake
I guess somebody Photoshop did or did
something which is weird cuz everybody
has a bunch of screenshots of him
posting it people to this hour still say
I saw the notification I clicked on it I
saw it on his Instagram but we don't
have a trailer right now so I apologize
for that
I know we've known it was fake and again
to this hour people still say it's real
so I I don't know if it was fake if the
corona buyer has pushed it back but you
know I'm sorry about that I mean I'm
just bummed because like you know we
were really looking forward to the
trailer we had a lot of like there's a
lot of anticipation we were having
airing in advance and a lot of research
- damn yeah I see you got the the venom
shirt on as well and you know John's on
the spider-man outfit there you know I'm
pretty bummed - I really thought I was
gonna be tomorrow because lots of people
said it was coming soon with that whole
thing and you know I'm really I'm really
sorry I
I guess the photo was fake so sorry
about that guys
it's like you broke my heart how like we
look on the internet every month like
real rejects said the truth was coming
out I subscribe to hit that notification
about fool just because of you you just
because of you what dumb people are like
you let us down reject nation's one
second hold on us [ __ ] Olivia we got
war on the phone you reported fake news
just typical media type [ __ ] you want
my girlfriend down you [ __ ] it's you
you know but other people reported it to
you know lots of people reported it I
wasn't the only one you know everybody
thought it was coming out tomorrow you
know wasn't just me that's fair I mean
it's not your fault sorry
what's this Fantastic Four video you put
up today John Krasinski met with people
from Marvel Studios and a lot of people
have been one of them for mr. fantastic
and got a lot of like evidence that
Fantastic Four is coming out soon so
seems like that could be why he met with
them via via zoom meeting so that's not
as cool that's pretty rad dude we should
react excited thanks man yeah yeah
alright see you buddy y'all man
you